se sabe que maldonado hacía parte del
programa de protección para periodistas
y ya había pedido ayuda al propio
presidente habló que falló
desafortunadamente vemos que de parte de
las autoridades no solamente del
gobierno federal pero también del
estatal hay una omisión por parte de
ellas para investigar los crímenes
contra periodistas y brindar la
protección debida a cada uno de cada una
de ellas en el caso de lourdes
completamente lamentable así como
también el de margarito martínez
periodista asesinado también en tijuana
el pasado lunes ellos nos contaban con
medidas de protección por parte de las
mismas autoridades sin embargo estamos
viendo que en el caso en las fiscalías
estatales así como la fiscalía general
de la república no realizan las debidas
diligencias para que puedan dar con los
responsables de estos crímenes y pues de
una vez por todas dar fin a la impunidad
que permite que estos mismos se
continúen nos estamos viendo que méxico
por esa misma razón es el país más
peligroso para la prensa en el mundo
porque si matan a un periodista no pasa
absolutamente nada sí y según reporteros
sin fronteras lo decía es el país más
mortífero del mundo para la prensa que
se necesita para que este tipo de hechos
como el de lourdes
presentando
se necesita que de una vez por todas en
el discurso oficial se dejan a un lado
las condenas y se pongan a actuar que se
pongan a investigar la fiscalía general
de la república tiene una fiscalía
especializada para la atención de
delitos cometidos contra la libertad de
expresión y tiene una facultad
constitucional para atraer por oficio
todos estos crímenes sin embargo vemos
que no es así también vemos que las
mismas fiscalías estatales no cuentan
con los recursos necesarios es decir no
solamente en términos financieros pero
también de capacidades de las mismas
personas que a los que pertenecen para
investigar debidamente por otra parte
vemos que en los mismos casos de
asesinatos de periodistas y de
agresiones de periodistas son
desestimados por las más autoridades
muchas veces descartan la línea en la
que existe un vínculo directo entre la
agresión y la labor que hacen los
compañeros